[Music]
the jungle this is a whole new thing
nobody told us we add it to a whole new
thing morning
did you guys see Spencer is that I think
he went back in we gotta go get it oh my
god my joints feel like myself I came
back and things actually got worse look
at this - the game is busted listen up
now this is a dangerous place you've got
to have eyes in the back
the Sam Hill just happened to him
hell is this
would you look at me I haven't looked
like this since never
you look like this never I think my eyes
are a different color all of you is a
different color strengths and weaknesses
linguistics
oh goodness nunchucks that's needle damn
that's a good list weaknesses heat Sun
and sang how is this guy a character in
an adventure game Bethenny the next
adventure is even more challenging this
time not all of you
Besame touch - now where is Bethany it's
right here she says oh my god like I'm a
total horse terrible joy what are you
talking about that's passed my driver's
test last month again
[Music]
yes I'm back I missed you so much oh my
god you guys hi Bethany you guys were
back in Jumanji
[Music]